[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in booger mcfarland the espn
nfl
analyst and part of espn's college
football and nfl coverage
booger good to see you how are you i'm
outstanding dp what's going on buddy
well i'm trying to understand
your former coach tony dungy's logic he
said that tom brady is the
sixth toughest quarterback that he had
to face
here um now i don't know if i'm missing
out on something because he is talking
about
quarterbacks that have mobility but uh
right he includes peyton manning in
there
and booger peyton manning doesn't have
mobility here
so does tony really think that tom brady
is the sixth
toughest quarterback to defend
well i i think that's a question that
you probably have to ask td
uh td probably has his reasons for that
you know you know
tom being in new england for 20 years uh
you hate to use the term system
quarterback dp but
he understood that system so well and he
played to it and i guarantee you if you
ask tony
playing that system over and over you
got used to it you knew what the checks
were you knew where the ball was going
to go you knew how tom brady
was going to play so maybe that lens to
tony saying okay
i don't know if he's that difficult to
prepare for because i know exactly
what he's going to do the key to it is
just can we go out and execute and stop
it
okay would you rather face brady or
manning
at their peak um wow
probably probably tom brady because
peyton manning did so much at the line
of scrimmage not
not that tom doesn't but manning called
the game
pretty much from the line tom brady was
more conventional so he was huddled
come to the line uh he made check every
now and then but you were gonna get the
game in
rhythm peyton manning was so much out of
rhythm because as a defensive lineman
he made you get on the ball and just
stand there and wait while he's omaha
and rabbit and ice cream and all the
other stuff that he's saying
like i gotta get out in the stands and
wait okay like i can't just
catch a couple of deep breaths whereas
with brady when brady's in the huddle
man i can grab some water
i can tuck my shirt in i can make sure
that my butt cracks not showing like i
can do all the things that defensive
linemen do
but what is it about brady in the final
two minutes of a game
that he's just different than almost any
quarterback we've ever seen
he's got ice water in his veins dp and
the great ones
look forward to the challenge of having
that opportunity in the final two
minutes
you know some quarterbacks can relish
the opportunity
some can perform in the opportunity it's
almost as if brady says okay
i'm gonna prepare for the rest of the
game but my mindset is always pointing
to
i want the ball in my hands under two
minutes
we're down four we need a touchdown i
want that opportunity because the great
ones know that in order to become great
you have to perform in those moments
like anybody can do it in the first
quarter when the game's not on the line
but if you want to be considered one of
the great ones you have to do it
it's kind of like in basketball we look
at lebron kobe all the great ones
differently
when they hit the game winners like you
can't be considered a great one until
you hit it's 5-4-3-2-1
and you hit the shot then we can put you
in a different category where it's no
different than
in football you got to take that team
down the field and score
in that drive like you got to perform in
a game seven
in baseball it's like our memory doesn't
doesn't
that doesn't put you in in stone or
concrete
until you do it in those moments what's
the craziest thing you've ever heard at
the line of scrimmage
um probably was against carson palmer
so carson palmer was quarterback in the
bengals
and it's a monday night and it's i want
to say it's late december
and of course everybody's banged up and
i'm banged up and tired and carson
palmer comes up and he's going no harder
and he's checking he's like hey let's go
to las vegas check check no no no no
let's go back
let's go to new york j.lo new york ready
and so he's calling all these audibles
and about the fourth player to drive it
took it kind of dawned on me wait
if he's saying a west coast city then
he's running to the left
if he's saying east coast city he's
running to the right and so
when he says vegas it's run left when he
says new york it's run right
and i was like so all the all this
credit that guys like you give these
quarterbacks
for all this great and being cerebral
here's the quarterback with the
really the most simplistic audible
system i've ever heard in my life
did you tell your teammates no because i
wanted to make every play man
at some point at some point you have to
be selfish because
if i make more plays that means i can
ask for more money with my contract
no i get it i get it i get it okay is
the jet's
job when it's open a good job
or a great job now good job
uh it's a good job because i think joe
douglas has done an outstanding job of
drafting
and especially in the last draft class
um
i think there are a couple of jobs that
are better if and when and i'm not going
to fire anybody but there's a lot of
speculation that the chargers job is
going to come open
that may be the best job on the market
if it does come open because of the
quarterback
because of what you have with bosa and
ingram on defense you have keenan allen
mike williams like you have
a team that if the ball bounces their
way they could have won four five more
games this year
i think the second best job that's going
to be open that is open
is the houston texans job because of the
quarterback now the only reason houston
is not first
is because of they got so much work to
do on on defense
and you know when jj watch your best
player on defense he's a hall of fame
player
three-time defensive player of the year
but let's face it he's not what he was
and so i think those are the top two
jobs now if the jets somehow finagle
and get the number one pick i would i
would bump them back up because if you
got trevor lawrence
with all the draft capital that they
have and joe douglas who seems to be a
really really good judge of talent
then that job really becomes attractive
i'm going to make you the jets gm right
now and you're on the clock with the
number two pick overall
what are you doing i am
looking at my phone seeing if the phone
is going to ring because if the phone
rings
for somebody who wants a quarterback
then i i'm going to deal
uh i'm going to keep sam donald i'm
going to pick up the fifth year option
because sam donald is not broken
sam donna is a very good quarterback and
with the right offensive mind i think
sam donald can be outstanding
adam gates has proven us as a matter of
fact adam gates told us with his own
words he failed sam donald
so sam donald is not broken i just think
the reason people were
tying trevor lawrence to the jets is
because we all think that
trevor lawrence is a generational talent
but i'm keeping sam donald
i'm trying to get a litany of picks and
if i can't get a litany of picks
then what i probably do i probably take
either jamar chase or the tackle i'm
gonna take uh
when i say the tackle penis sula out of
oregon i'm gonna take somebody that's
gonna boost my offense to help sam
donald
uh if i don't get a trade partner at
number two
we're talking to booger mcfarland you
can uh see him on espn's college
football coverage and their nfl coverage
as well you know you start to look at
the playoff scenarios here
and we might have a team have what 11
wins and not make the playoffs here
which is is pretty crazy
uh if you were going to let's look at
the afc the the teams the number of
teams let's take out the chiefs the
number of teams that you go
they they can win the super bowl
uh buffalo is one tennessee's two
indianapolis three
um it sounds crazy not to say pittsburgh
but
how can you say pittsburgh the way
they've looked the last three weeks and
and quite frankly you know i said this
uh on our pregame show a couple of weeks
ago pittsburgh has it has a softness
problem like
they're very soft uh especially on the
offensive line
and you know they kind of got in an
uproar when i said that but then the
head coach
mike tomlin came by and said there was a
lack of physicality
ben roethlisberger said there was a lack
of physicality
it's a team that's trying to play an
offense in which they're not familiar
how to play
it it's four or five wide they're trying
to be the kansas city chiefs but they
got a quarterback
and ben roethlisberger that i mean let's
face it he he he's on hold 16.
like like he he's he's getting ready to
come down the 16th fairway
and it's like hey big fella you ain't
got a long left and he knows it and
everybody knows it
and for them to play and play at a high
level
they're going to have to run the
football but they can't dan and that's
the issue so
you know my short list of teams after
kansas city would be
um obviously you know tennessee
in the buffalo would probably be the
three other than kansas city that i
would lean on
yeah the thing with the steelers you
know and then ben says he wants to come
back who's more likely to be back
with their team ben or phillip rivers
likely and drew brees
well i believe drew brees is going to be
your colleague and work for
nbc peacock whatever you want to call it
i i think that's where he's going i
think phillip
wants to go coach high school football
uh that's why he i think he signed a
one-year deal
i think you know big ben's coming back
man big ben's got 30 million
dollars that's sitting there that i mean
it's kind of free money like they're not
going to cut him
he's a legend he can kind of go
cherry-pick kind of like some of the
great basketball players do he can
average
you know 10 points and three rebounds
and get 25 million bucks
so i mean if i were him that's what i do
but if you're the steelers do you want
him back
what's your alternative mason rudolph
duck hodges
well i they're gonna they're gonna get
rid of those guys but if you said that
you could get
sam darnold i think you asked ben to
retire if you could get sam donald
because sam donna could be a quarterback
for 10 years
to me dan here's he here's the
quarterback carousel watch this now
okay let's just say somehow um the jets
get the first pick
so now sam donald is now being traded
let's just say sam darnold
is traded uh or he goes to indy or
maybe indy maybe sam donald goes to san
francisco because we know they're not
necessarily sold on jimmy where does
jimmy
go does jimmy g go to new england okay
you see how one pick can change the
entire outlook of this league
because there could be a lot of
quarterbacks on the move what if
arthur blank and the new coach decide we
want to move away from matt ryan
i can see matt ryan going to san
francisco then where does jimmy g go so
i think the quarterback carousel is
going to be really
interesting and we thought last year was
interesting i think this
offseason with the quarterbacks that
could be on the move potentially is
going to be
way more intriguing than it was last
year you think cam
is one and done in new england yes
because i think cam in new england
uh both had a vested interest in this
season they both needed each other
and they both have failed cam newton
needed new england
because he needed to prove that he could
still be a high level starting
quarterback
in the national football league in hopes
of getting a huge deal he has not done
that
he's still bouncing balls to receivers
overthrowing receivers
his best trait is his physicality and
you wonder how long that can last
um new england needed to see can cam do
it because we have to find the heir
apparently tom brady
and josh mcdaniel and bill belichick in
a private moment will probably tell you
that they weren't able to maximize and
get the best out of camp
josh can't be who josh wants to be with
the guy who's limited as a pastor
so i think they both failed each other
do you understand
sean payton's fixation on taysom hill
uh i do because i think in sean payton's
mind he sees
what a lot of these offensive
coordinators have right now
a dual threat quarterback that can hurt
you with his legs the problem is
tayson hasn't gotten enough reps
throwing the football and the only way
you get reps
is guess what you got you got to put him
in the game and we didn't have a
pre-season this year
didn't have really off-season in
off-season and so taysom hill
needs reps to me it's going to really
come down to
after because i think drew brees is
going to retire when drew brees retires
i think sean payton is going to name
taysom hill at starting quarterback
he's going to get an entire offseason
mini camp training camp
preseason if we do have a pre-season and
he's going to give him every opportunity
and if he fails at that point then he'll
move on but i i do think he's invested
a lot of time and effort into making
taysom hill what
his mind says taysom can be which is the
second coming of steve young
oh yeah good luck with that
uh yeah that's what he i mean he tells
everybody that right yeah but he's not
because steve has
wonderful touch taysom wasn't a great
passer in college
and it's not like you go i wasn't very
good in college as a passer but i'm
going to get better in the nfl as a
passer
i mean that yeah i think josh had
mechanics
i think he had some and plus if you saw
the wyoming roster and you saw the
weather they played in
then i can at least go okay um you know
a lot of it's decision making a lot of
it's
that i got to throw a receiver open in
in college
i can imagine duane haskins at ohio
state
right he didn't have to throw anybody
open justin fields
you know like you're it's hard to really
handicap and go i don't know how good
these guys are
and with josh allen he probably is
learning to throw
you know guys open here and he's done a
great job this year
and to your point dan uh josh allen has
gotten better mechanics where they
play a part you know you bring up justin
fields
and i think people are going to be
shocked
when they really get into the justin
fields tape how
similar he is to yes he's more athletic
than
um yeah way more athletic
however from a passing standpoint he's
going to resemble haskins a lot
the anticipation is just a step slow his
ability to throw guys open
is a step slow i think zach wilson on a
byu
may be the second quarterback taken and
i think a lot of people will be shocked
by that
because all along it's been trevor or
justin trevor justin
i think when it's all said and done it's
going to be trevor probably zach wilson
maybe even a mac jones behind that i
don't think justin fields is being
helped
based on when you look at how dwayne
haskins is performing coming out of that
same system
what are what's in those cabinets behind
you
um the one over this shoulder i got a
lot of apple products in there so i got
some extra
like some old ipads iphones etc
this cabinet i have extra checkbooks
because i'm still old school so i don't
do everything by
by uh ach or auto pay like i still write
checks
so i got checks in that cabinet i got
some vitamins up there
because when i'm in the office i forget
to take my vitamins there up there
so this is kind of a multi-purpose
cabinet yeah yeah we got to do something
in the background i got to get some
you got to dress it up a little bit
there should be a picture of the one nfl
touchdown that you had
yes the problem is uh i was so out of
breath
the only picture i have of that
touchdown literally my shirt is pulled
up like my gut's hanging out
and i mean seriously because it was in
atlanta it was sad cause fumble
following the ball in atlanta against
michael vick
and it was so funny the only thing i
thought about was
i have to come right back on the field
because i scored the touchdown and our
defense is going back on the field
that's the mind of a defensive lineman
it's not celebrate it's not do a tick
tock on the logo
it's hey let's go get some water and get
ready to come back on the field
uh and you're trying to track down
michael vick
exactly you know we
kyler murray i think is quicker than
mike i think mike might
be faster kyler murray has that
acceleration
he gets to a different gear i think
quicker than anybody i've ever seen at
that position
yes i would agree with you and he has to
he's five eight
nine whatever you want to call he's not
six feet tall so he's got to use
his attributes to help him and i i think
when he struggled over the last i mean
couple weeks
his ability or or her team's ability to
keep him in the pocket
so if i'm going against kyle murray dan
watch what the patriots did to him
the patriots didn't allow him outside
the pocket and it's very similar to
baker mayfield
if you just keep baker mayfield in the
confines of that pocket
he's going to struggle more times than
not because these guys are not very big
now the coaching staffs know that so
what does kevin stefanski do
what does cliff kingsbury do i'm gonna
get these guys outside the pocket on the
edge where they can see
imagine if you were trying to drive a
car you couldn't see
like you couldn't drive at all so like
these dudes
uh did these dudes have rare traits but
they got to be able to
be put in position to use those traits
it's great to talk to you
uh you brought it today we appreciate it
i uh
didn't expect anything less booger part
of espn's college football
uh nfl coverage merry christmas to you
bud and uh we hope to talk to you again
soon
thank you always man love you pal you
take it easy tell the damn that's how i
say hello
that's booger mcfarland